This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. When Herbie Miller was growing up in East Kingston, Jamaica in the 1950s, he and his friends would put on their best outfits and head into the city. From blocks away, they get your music pumping out through giant, powerful speakers set up at dance halls, bars, and social clubs all over downtown. The sound was irresistible and so herbie and its crew would just follow their ears. Along the way they'd run into other kids like them, everyone looking for the exact same thing, the perfect dance party.
这里是《99% Invisible》，我是罗曼·马尔斯。20世纪50年代，赫比·米勒在牙买加东金斯顿长大，那时他和朋友们会穿上最体面的衣服进城。隔着几个街区，你就能听到从市中心各处的舞厅、酒吧和社交俱乐部里，巨大的强力音箱传出的震撼音乐。那种声音让人无法抗拒，于是赫比和他的伙伴们就循声而去。一路上，他们会遇到其他像他们一样的孩子，每个人都在寻找同样的东西——一场完美的舞会。
Packs of boys are groups of boys walking from community to community, unable to go inside clubs and dance halls because it was perhaps two shillings and six pence that was the entropy to our dance. The guys would collect scrap metal and recycle empty bottles just to earn enough cash to pay the door. But sometimes they'd still come up short. That's 99 PI producer, Christopher Johnson.
成群结队的男孩们从一个社区走到另一个社区，却无法进入俱乐部和舞厅，因为入场费可能要两先令六便士，那是我们进入舞会的门槛。小伙子们会收集废金属和回收空瓶子，只为攒够门票钱。但有时他们还是凑不够。这是《99 PI》的制作人克里斯托弗·约翰逊。
These parties were the hottest dance scene on the island, with DJ spinning the latest tracks by artists like Alton Ellis, Don Drummond, and Roland Alfonso. That music made the party so live that things were even popping out on the street. So that's the dance outside and you listen to the tune outside, then you have the orange man, the juice man, all of these were on the outside of the dance, say about piece of K&A and go on eating your K&R and you're too sour to make a pocket cannon for it. Say you know, it was a lot of fun. And then if they got lucky, a sympathetic bouncer would eventually open the gate and wave
这些派对是岛上最火爆的舞场，DJ们播放着奥尔顿·埃利斯、唐·德拉蒙德和罗兰·阿方索等艺术家的最新曲目。音乐让派对气氛极其热烈，甚至连街上都热闹非凡。舞会在里面，你在外面听着曲子，外面还有卖橙子的人、卖果汁的人，所有这些人都在舞会外面，吃着烤肉，喝着酸味饮料，玩得非常开心。如果运气好，通情达理的保镖最终会打开大门，挥手示意。
herbie in his body through. And oh my god, that's when herbie really felt it. But the first thing I'm going to walk inside, the weirdt other music hit you in your chest. The beast that can earth beat, you feel that beast inside that. If you don't feel the beast, there is no beast. Herbie love that muscular sound system. His bones rattled and buzzed from those driving dance beats coming from the R&B, Soul, Jazz, and Skull records that the DJs were spending.
让赫比和他的伙伴们进去。天哪，那才是赫比真正感受到音乐的时候。刚走进去，那奇怪的音乐就直击你的胸膛。那种心跳般的节奏，你能感觉到那种节奏在体内跳动。如果你感觉不到那种节奏，那它就不存在。赫比热爱那种充满力量的音响系统。当DJ播放R&B、灵魂乐、爵士乐和斯卡唱片时，那些强劲的舞曲节奏让他的骨头都在震动和嗡嗡作响。
He'd find a spot next to a refrigerator-sized speaker box called a House of Joy and just take in the ground. To watch the nice girls come into the dances and their dance to the door and to watch the old badman walk, old badman talk, old badman profile, you know, the old thing man. As the men and women walked into the dance, young herbids had known of what everyone was wearing. These folks were sharp. It was just a colorful scene to see that people decked out coming on and I'm terrible and I'm a little bit more terrible and I'm a little bit more terrible and I'm
他会找个地方，靠着一个冰箱大小的音箱——他们叫它“欢乐之家”——静静地享受。看着漂亮的女孩们走进舞池，看着老派的“坏小子”们走路、谈话、摆姿势，你知道的，就是那种老派作风。当男男女女走进舞池时，年轻的赫比会留意每个人的穿着。这些人打扮得非常时髦。那是一个色彩斑斓的场景，人们盛装出席，每个人都比别人更酷一点。
a little bit more terrible and I'm a little bit more terrible and I'm a little bit more and fell hats and ties and people were just at them best, but these were working people. I mean, they all started, but that part was done. For Herbie, one of the best parts of the night was when the crowd would form a ring and the expert dancers would enter the circle. A man danced until the close tick on to him. He has to abandon him nice continental, jacquita and dance down to him. Sure less, the way a perspiration is oozing out of his body.
戴着毡帽，系着领带，人们都展现出最好的状态，但他们其实都是劳动人民。对我来说，夜晚最棒的部分之一是人群围成一个圈，专家级的舞者走进圆圈中央。男人跳舞直到衣服贴在身上。他必须抛开他那体面的大陆风格夹克，尽情跳舞，汗水从他身上渗出来。
They get so hot that onlookers would splash the dancers with cold beer until the floor was a slurry of sweat and red stripe. Come on, man, it just was an amazing spectacle to be horny. When Herbie was growing up, these amazing parties, sometimes called Laundances or Blues Dances, they were happening on the regular all over downtown Kingston. And one of the things that made these jams burn so damn hot was the technology that powered the party.
他们跳得太热了，旁观者会用冰啤酒泼向舞者，直到地板变成汗水和红带啤酒的混合物。天哪，那真是一场令人惊叹的奇观。赫比成长时期，这些被称为“草坪舞会”或“蓝调舞会”的精彩派对，在金斯顿市中心随处可见。让这些派对如此火爆的原因之一，是驱动派对的技术。
Jamaica is famous around the world for its music, like Skah, Dub, and Reggae. It's tempting to think that those powerful amplifiers and giant speakers were designed to perfectly capture Jamaica's indigenous sounds. But it's actually the other way around. Those speakers and amps came first, and the electricians, mechanics, and engineers who built and adapted that technology would then play a decisive role in the creation of Jamaica's modern music. They help pioneer approaches to making and performing music that would spawn whole other scenes
牙买加因其音乐而闻名于世，如斯卡、配乐和雷鬼。人们很容易认为那些强大的放大器和巨大的音箱是为了完美捕捉牙买加本土声音而设计的。但事实恰恰相反。是先有了那些音箱和放大器，而建造和改装这些技术的电工、机械师和工程师们，随后在牙买加现代音乐的创造中发挥了决定性作用。他们帮助开创了制作和表演音乐的方法，从而催生了其他整个音乐场景。
from the Bronx to the UK. These dance parties first emerged in Jamaica in the decade following World War II. That's when the deeply underdeveloped British colony started to grow economically. One big boost came from US tourism. This then is Jamaica, an exotic blend of old world and new. Americans came in droves to visit the resorts that were popping up all along the sublime with coast.
从布朗克斯到英国。这些舞会最早出现在二战后的牙买加。那时，这个极度不发达的英国殖民地开始在经济上增长。一个巨大的推动力来自美国旅游业。这就是牙买加，一个旧世界与新世界交织的异国情调之地。美国人成群结队地来到这里，参观沿着绝美海岸线涌现的度假村。
You'd have to go a long way to find anything to compare. Plains from New York, 1600 miles away, landed Montego Bay Airport barely six hours later. As US visitors flock to the island, hotels scramble to meet their demands, which could sometimes be a little particular. Because I don't mean to be rude about Americans. Lloyd Bradley is a music historian, a British music historian.
你很难找到与之媲美的地方。从1600英里外的纽约起飞的飞机，仅仅六小时后就降落在蒙特哥湾机场。随着美国游客涌入岛上，酒店争相满足他们的需求，这些需求有时可能有点挑剔。我并不是想对美国人无礼。劳埃德·布拉德利是一位音乐历史学家，一位英国音乐历史学家。
Every American I've ever met, except for two or three actually, would have been abroad, or essentially looking for America with a more agreeable climate. US vacationers wanted something familiar, especially when it came to entertainment. And so as the North Coast Hotel business started booming, so there was a demand for dance bands, big band jazz, swing, essentially American music played by Jamaican musicians in the hotels, you know, because the idea of recreating something as
我见过的每一个美国人，除了两三个之外，基本上都是在寻找一个气候更宜人的美国。美国度假者想要一些熟悉的东西，尤其是在娱乐方面。因此，随着北海岸酒店业的蓬勃发展，对舞团、大乐队爵士乐、摇摆乐的需求也随之增加，本质上就是牙买加音乐人在酒店演奏美国音乐，因为在这些酒店里尽可能地重现美国风格，会让游客更容易融入其中。其他游客来到牙买加是想听牙买加的音乐，所以很多酒店也雇佣了专门演奏岛上民间音乐的乐队。度假小镇对艺术家的需求如此之高，以至于引发了音乐人从首都金斯顿的大规模外流。他们中的许多人收拾起萨克斯和吉他，前往旅游热点。
American as possible in these hotels would make it very easy for tourists to so sneak into it. Other tourists came to Jamaica wanting to hear music from Jamaica, so lots of hotels also hired bands that specialize in the island's folk music. The demand for artists in the resort towns was so high, it sparked an exodus of musicians out of the capital city of Kingston. Many of them packed up their saxophones and guitars and struck out for tourist hot spots
寻找报酬更高的演出。像安东尼奥港、蒙特哥湾这样的地方对受过训练的音乐人有很大的吸引力。也正是在这个时候，许多受过训练的音乐人离开了牙买加。音乐历史学家诺曼·斯托尔索夫说，许多牙买加艺术家也加入了西印度群岛人的大规模移民潮，前往英国、美国和加拿大。受过训练的音乐人离开了首都，这使得20世纪40年代末的普通金斯顿人几乎没有现场音乐的选择。当时娱乐活动相当匮乏，音乐娱乐活动，实际上是大众可获得的乐队音乐短缺。但看，那些人仍然想跳舞和聚会。因此，金斯顿中部和西部的一小部分小商人、发明家和音频工程师开始即兴创作，为人们提供他们渴望的舞会，而无需任何现场音乐人。
in search of higher paying gigs. Places like Port Antonio, Montego Bay was a big draw for train musicians. And it was also at this time that many of the trained musicians left Jamaica. Music historian Norman Stollsoff says that lots of Jamaican artists also joined a mass migration of West Indians who headed to the UK, the US, and Canada. Train musicians were leaving the capital city, and that left the average King Stoney in the
这一切始于那些将唱片播放器连接到非常基础的扩声系统上的店主。他们把音箱放在店外，播放录制好的音乐来吸引顾客。这奏效了，某种程度上，因为人们没有进店，而是聚集在街上跳舞。其他一些企业家看到了其中的巨大潜力，于是他们组装了自己的扩声系统和唱机，并带着这些设备在金斯顿四处奔波。
late 1940s with few options for live music. There was kind of a dearth of entertainment, musical entertainment, literally a shortage of banned music available to the masses of Jamaicans. But look, those folks still wanted to dance and party. So a handful of small businessmen, inventors, and audio engineers across Central and West Kingston began to improvise a way to give the people the dance parties that they craved without any live musicians.
在露天场地，或者酒吧后面的院子里举办小型舞会，只要有空间就行。他们开始在家庭聚会上播放音乐，用他们的唱机和小型音箱，这些聚会变得非常受欢迎。填补了早期乐队所扮演的角色。由于没有音乐人，这些音响系统乐队就介入了。尽管规模很小，但这些派对很快激发了技术上的重大进步。而这项技术将帮助西金斯顿萌芽中的场景爆发。大约在1950年，一位名叫赫德利·琼斯的牙买加发明家利用他作为英国皇家空军前雷达工程师的知识，制造了一种新型的强大动态放大器。
It all started with shop owners who were connecting record players to very basic PA systems. They placed the speakers outside their stores and play recorded music to try and attract customers. And it works, sort of, because instead of going inside the store, some folks would just gather on the street and dance. A few other entrepreneurs saw real potential on this, so they put together their own PA turntable units and they took those setups around Kingston,
它是专门为DJ设计的。该放大器具有所谓的“三频均衡器”，可以分离并强调高、中、低频。所以，实际上，当你想要DJ增强低音时，他现在可以增强低音了。一位名叫“伟大的塞巴斯蒂安汤姆”的五金店老板是第一批将赫德利·琼斯的新放大器连接到他的唱机和音箱上的人之一。
hosting little dances in open air lots, or maybe in the yard behind a bar, wherever there was space. They started playing house parties, small gatherings with their record players and small speakers and they became quite popular. Filling in that role that bands would have played in earlier time. And musicians weren't available, so these sound system bands kind of stepped in. As small as they were, these parties would soon inspire some big advances in technology. And that tech was going to help West Kingston's nascent scene, explode. Right around 1950, a Jamaican inventor named Headley Jones used his knowledge as a former radar engineer for the British Royal Air Force to build a new kind of powerful dynamic
他给那套强大的装备起了一个新名字：音响系统。西金斯顿的舞会场景从舒适的家庭聚会扩展到社交俱乐部、空置建筑和大型露天草坪上的大型活动，要让所有人跳舞，现在需要一个强大的运营团队。音响系统中的一切都变得越来越大：放大器、音箱和音箱箱体。是的，因为你知道，那个时代之后，人们开始在一个箱子里放两个音箱，把箱子做得更大，使其更强大。这是金·杰米，一位传奇的音响系统操作员和音乐制作人。当这些第一批音响系统流行时，他还是个孩子。所以当时大多数大型音响系统都使用双音箱，他们开始使用更大的放大器来驱动音箱，从而获得更大的功率。到这一点，短语“音响系统”的含义也扩大了。它不仅仅是设备。音响系统还包括操作它所需的所有人员：所有者、DJ和工程师。
amplifier. It was designed specifically for DJs. The amp had what's called a three-band equalizer, which could separate out and then emphasize high, mid, and low frequencies. So, practically speaking, when you wanted a DJ to pump that bass, he could now pump that bass. A hardware store owner whose DJ name was Tom the Great Sebastian was one of the first to wire Heideley Jones' new amp to his turntable and speakers.
到50年代初，金斯顿及其周边地区有近十几支专业的顶级音响系统团队。这些团队，有时简称为“音响”，陷入了一场全面的技术军备竞赛，看谁能建造最大的装备。如果你看过音响系统装备的照片，你知道，那些高耸的音箱墙，就是从这里开始的。受过电气工程和木工训练的人们将进口设备与各种备件混合搭配，修补、焊接、锤击、布线和重新布线，所有这些都是为了建造出声音如此清晰、如此强大，以至于能压倒城里所有其他DJ团队的放大器和音箱单元。在他的雷鬼音乐历史书《低音文化》中，劳埃德·布拉德利讲述了一个关于一位旨在粉碎竞争对手的DJ的故事。是的，当时确实发生了一些事情。
And he gave that powerful rig a new name, the Sound System. West Kingston's dance scene expanded from cozy house parties to larger affairs in social clubs, empty buildings, and large open lawns to keep all those people dancing and now took a robust operation. And everything in the sound system just got bigger and bigger, the amps, the speakers, and the speaker cabinets. Yes, because you know what, those days after that era I'd gone with the one speaker box,
我的意思是，这可能是一个问题，但这只是为了娱乐，为了忽略。故事是这样的，一位音响技术员从牙买加飞往迈阿密，他在一家船舶设备经销商处停留。那种为船只提供航海所需一切用品的地方。浏览了一会儿后，他告诉热情的推销员他的购物清单：航海级扬声器。他买了一对用于在雾中警告船只的音箱，你知道，他唯一关心的是，它能否承受5000瓦的功率，这就是他打算通过它输出的功率。这真是一件大事，你知道。这些家伙会不惜一切代价，去任何地方，只为得到最大、最强大的音响系统。尽管技术至关重要且令人印象深刻，但如果没有实际的音乐，当然就没有音响系统。唱片是音响的生命线。但虽然早期的音响系统操作员已经改造了他们的设备，使其成为他们自己的东西，但实际上几乎没有任何音乐是牙买加的。第一批音响系统舞会播放的是R&B，是进口的美国唱片，因为当时牙买加没有制作任何唱片。让亲戚从纽约寄来一箱箱唱片更容易。好吧，你仍然进口唱片。但我说“我们”，我是指音响系统的人，你知道。蒙蒂·布莱克是音响系统的皇室成员。他的父亲在1950年创办了马里通音响。今天，蒙蒂经营着牙买加最古老的活跃音响系统——马里通。
people started to make two speakers in a box now, make the box bigger to make it more powerful. This is King Jammy, a legendary sound system operator and music producer. He was still a kid when these first sound systems were raining. So you had most of the big sounds in those days, going with double speakers, and they started to be the bigger amplifiers to drive the speakers more, so they get more power. By this point, the meaning of the phrase sound system had also expanded. It wasn't just the equipment. A sound system was also all the people it took to operate it, the owners, the DJs, and
当蒙蒂还是个孩子时，他和他的兄弟们会带着接收器和天线爬上屋顶，天线大到足以接收美国的R&B、爵士乐和蓝调广播节目。他们一直在寻找可以通过邮购订购的歌曲，以喂养家庭音响系统。我们过去常在晚上加入。那是晚上12点，当信号清晰的时候。
the engineers. By the early 50s, there were close to a dozen professional top-ranking sound system crews in and around Kingston. And these crews, sometimes just called sounds, were locked in a full-on technological arms race to see who could build the biggest rig. If you've seen pictures of sound system rigs, you know, the towering walls of speakers, this is where it begins. Guys who were trained in electrical engineering and cabinetry mixed and matched imported equipment
我们会接收到纳什维尔的电台。我们会听并进口这些唱片。所以我们过去常从纳什维尔的电台获取唱片。不，这在维亚纳之前，我不知道。那是虫胶唱片，78转，易碎的东西。牙买加人喜欢这些东西。音乐中低音和鼓声很重，在每天变得越来越强大的音响系统上听起来非常好。我要找到我的宝贝，我今晚就要找到它。
with miscellaneous spare parts, tinkering, soldering, hammering, wiring and rewiring, all in the quest to build amp and speaker units that pumped out sound so clear and so powerful they crush every other DJ crew in town. In his book on the history of reggae music, called Bass Culture, Lloyd Bradley relates a story that he was told about one DJ who was out to pulverize the competition. Yeah, there was something going on.
我们过去常从新奥尔良进口大量音乐，路易斯·乔丹，埃拉斯科·加登斯。戴夫·巴托洛姆的任何作品，你对路易斯微笑。哦，雷德。你要做什么？哦，雷德。我厌倦了你。音响系统团队也找到了其他方法来获取他们需要的唱片。他们中的许多人依赖像克莱门特·西摩·多德这样的人。小时候，他赢得了“考克斯森”的绰号，源自一位著名的英国板球运动员。20世纪50年代初，多德在美国南部做过短暂的移民农场工人。这些工作让他接触到了大量的黑人舞曲和黑人舞会。他看到了户外派对是多么有利可图。多德带着一箱箱待售的唱片回到了牙买加。他成为了金斯顿音响人的生命线，他们依靠他供应新鲜音乐。多德并不是唯一这样做的人，但他对这个场景的参与远不止运输唱片。他很快将在塑造现代牙买加音乐方面发挥决定性作用。在灵魂爵士唱片公司2002年的纪录片《一号录音室的故事》中，多德描述了他在50年代初是如何开始与当时最大的音响系统操作员之一——一个叫杜克·里德的人——进行DJ客串表演的。他是家里的朋友。所以我有了唱片。所以我过去常四处走动，在他的音响系统上播放它们，所以我可以看到舞迷们会如何接受它。
I mean, again, this might be a problem, but it's something that, you know, it's just to entertain, to ignore. As the story goes, a sound technician flew from Jamaica to Miami and he stopped at a marine equipment dealership. The sort of place that supplies boats with all the things they need for seafaring. After browsing for a bit, he told his eager salesman what was on his shopping list, nautical grade loudspeakers. And he bought a couple of speakers that were used to warn ships in folk, you know, and all he was concerned about was,
在他的音响系统上。在他的音响系统上。你想炫耀什么？这对他的帮助很大，因为我播放了他甚至不知道的唱片。多德是一位狂热的音乐迷。他非常熟悉这些唱片，并且知道如何从美国获得更多。
would it take 5,000 watts, which is why he was going to put through it? It was a real big deal, you know. These guys would do anything go anywhere to get their hands on the biggest and most powerful sound systems. As vital and impressive as the tech was, there was of course no sound system without the actual music. Records were the lifeblood of the sound. But while the early sound system operators had reconstructed their equipment to make it their own. Virtually none of the actual music was Jamaican. The first sound system, dances, were R&B, were imported American records because there weren't
但他自己并没有真正演奏任何乐器。他是一位受过训练的汽车修理工和木匠，一位左脑技术员，有为其他音响系统团队建造音箱箱体的经验。他意识到他拥有开始自己音响系统所需的所有技能。他确实这么做了。他称之为“考克斯森爵士的节拍”。考克斯森爵士很快成为他那个时代首屈一指的音响人之一，以在更可预测的R&B舞曲中加入波普和蓝调片段而闻名。到50年代中期，金斯顿音响系统舞会场景变得非常拥挤。
any records being made in Jamaica. It was easier to have a relative send boxes of records from New York or something. Well, you still import records. But I say we, I mean, the sound system people, you know. Monty Blake is sound system royalty. His dad started Maritone Sound in 1950. Today Monty operates Maritone, the oldest active sound system in Jamaica.
经营它们的人来自各行各业。多德曾是一名移民农民和汽车修理工。杜克·里德是一位前警察，以在舞会上公开携带上膛枪支而闻名。杜克·里德、考克斯森·多德和其他音响人经常发现自己在彼此隔壁播放音乐，争夺寻找最佳跳舞地点的派对参与者的注意力。所以最初会有两个或更多的舞厅表演在同一个社区竞争，看谁能吸引更多的人群。表达方式是，所有的人群都去了你的舞会而不是另一个，你就“搞砸了”另一个音响人的舞会。没过多久，一些推广人决定让事情变得更有趣。通过让音响系统进行正面交锋，有点像乐队大战。这些成为了现在所谓的“音响系统冲突”，两个或更多的音响系统会在竞争激烈的音乐战斗中相互对抗。
When Monty was a kid, he and his brothers would climb up on their roof with a receiver and an antenna that was big enough to pick up R&B, jazz, and blues radio shows in the US. They were listening for songs that they could order by mail just to feed the family sound system. We used to join in that night. That's 12 o'clock at night when it's clear.
在冲突中，每个音响系统通常会获得一定的播放时间。他们会来回切换，试图赢得人群明确的爱。在他的职业生涯早期，考克斯森与像杜克·里德这样的资深音响人进行冲突。这些胜利至关重要，因为它们帮助确立了考克斯森作为业内最好的音响系统操作员之一的地位。赢得音响冲突和举办令人难忘的舞会不仅仅是为了吹牛。在短短几年内，音响系统场景变得极其有利可图，不仅支持音响团队，还支持安保人员、司机、场地所有者等。这不仅是音响系统及其支持者的吹牛权利，而且经济生存也与谁最终会赢得冲突息息相关。水果和鱼贩、烤鸡摊贩，所有依赖这个本土场景的人都会涌向舞会大门。音响系统在很多行业中扮演着非常重要的角色。这是金·杰米再次发言。它在人们在舞会上销售东西方面发挥着至关重要的作用。它对卖大麻的人和很多事情都很重要，你知道。所以它成为了一种非正式经济，为那些长期就业不足并寻找赚外快方法的人提供了机会。
And we would pick up, you know, the stations in Nashville. And we would listen and import the records. So we used to get records from urnies and rand stations in Nashville. Then we would listen and import the records. So we used to get records from earnings and randis in Nashville. No, this was before Viana, I don't know. They were shell-ock records, 78 RPM, the breakable stuff. Jamaica's love this stuff. The music was heavy on bass and drums, and it sounded really good on the sound systems that were growing more and more powerful every day. I'm gonna find my baby, I'm gonna find it tonight.
当谈到保持领先于竞争对手时，音响系统团队可能会无情。在冲突中，一个团队甚至可能采取破坏手段，切断音箱线或引发斗殴，只是为了破坏竞争对手。还有其他DJ团队为了保持领先而战斗的方式。看，许多金斯顿人依靠音响系统派对来听新音乐。大多数人没有唱片播放器，牙买加电台也没有播放他们想听的前卫或派对曲目。所以如果你喜欢那种东西，你就必须去舞会。而这正是金斯顿人所做的。他们前往音响系统派对，期待DJ播放最新鲜的曲目。这就是为什么音响人能拥有的最珍贵的东西是一首新的、别人都没有的歌。它们被称为“独家”。很多音乐是由像考克斯森·多德这样的人进口或带到牙买加的。对于大多数DJ来说，这些唱片是无价的。音乐方面确实是关于拥有独家作品。弗兰克·布劳顿是《昨晚DJ救了我的命：DJ历史》一书的合著者。
We used to import a lot of music out of New Orleans, the Louis Jordan, the Erasco Gardens. Anything by Dave Bartolom, you smile the Louis. Oh, Red. What you gonna do? Oh, Red. I'm sick and tired of you. Sound system crews also found other ways
音响系统的家伙们会去美国获取节奏蓝调唱片，这完全取决于你能获得哪些独家曲目，这些曲目会让你的对手没有的人群疯狂。他们有标志性的曲调，可能是岛上唯一的副本。音响系统之间的竞争变得无情。他们派人去美国进行侦察探险以寻找唱片。然后还有很多侦探工作试图找出你的竞争对手的唱片是什么，或者他们正在保密什么。为了独家，你应该刮掉标签。蒙蒂·布莱克，他的父亲创办了马里通音响系统，记得音响人为了保持唱片超级秘密而采取的极端措施。因为那些日子你有间谍。
to get their hands on the records they needed. Many of them relied on men like Clement Seymour Dodd. As a kid, he'd earned the nickname Caw Coxson after a well-known British cricket player. In the early 1950s, Dodd did some brief stretches as a migrant farm worker in the American South. Those gigs gave him lots of exposure to black dance music and to black dance parties. He saw how lucrative an outdoor jam could be. Dodd returned to Jamaica with boxes of records for sale. He became a lifeline for Kingston
他们知道颜色，一旦他们看到黄色和黑色，他们就知道是Specialty，他们看到红色和黑色，他们就知道是Atlantic。金·杰米说，这种做法对于经营音响系统的人来说非常普遍。刮掉名字，没人真正知道是谁在唱，或者歌名是什么。所以播放器是独家歌曲，他们会播放几个月，直到你知道，直到另一个人发现歌手是谁或歌名是什么。在抹去艺术家和唱片公司的名字后，音响人有时甚至会重命名现在匿名的曲调。然后他们在派对上播放新曲目，人们会疯狂。至少，那是梦想。整个过程是DJ文化中变得非常熟悉的事情的最早迭代之一。
Soundman, who relied on him for a supply of fresh music. Dodd wasn't the only migrant farm worker doing this, but his involvement in the scene went way beyond just transporting records. He would soon play a decisive role in the shaping of modern Jamaican music. In the 2002 documentary, The Studio One Story, by SoulJazz Records, Dodd describes how in the early 50s, he started doing DJ guest spots with one of the biggest sound system operators at the time. A guy named Duke Reed. was a friend of the family. So I had the records. So I used to go around, play them on his own system, so I was to see how the dance fan would accept it.
那个获得所有音乐爱戴的人并不是真正创作它的人。是DJ。赞誉归功于他阅读人群的技巧、他的音乐品味以及他获得最佳舞曲的能力。但到了20世纪50年代下半叶，多年来一直让音响系统DJ的板条箱里装满爵士乐、蓝调和R&B唱片的美国到牙买加的管道开始枯竭。这即将成为舞会的一个问题。怪摇滚乐吧。在美国，节奏蓝调有点过时了。然后是摇滚乐。但摇滚乐在牙买加并没有产生强烈的影响。摇滚乐在20世纪50年代中期爆发。但凭借其推搡、蜿蜒的吉他和没有明显的舞曲节奏，西金斯顿的派对人群并不买账。随着摇滚乐在美国成为主流，像多德这样的音响人发现越来越难获得牙买加人喜欢的、那种低音沉重的爵士乐和R&B，而且在那些巨大的音箱上听起来很棒。实际上，美国正在耗尽这些东西。到那时，品味正在转变。没有那么多路易斯·乔丹之类的东西了。
On his own system. On his own system. What are you trying to out on? This was doing a lot for him because I was playing record that he didn't even know. Dott was a huge music fan. He was very familiar with these records and he knew how to get more from the US.
与此同时，周围有更多的音响系统，每个人都在从这个日益减少的新鲜美国R&B池中汲取资源。多德和其他人可以看到墙上的字迹。他们在音响系统业务上投入了很多，而且回报不错，但前提是你必须保持竞争优势，而这变得越来越难。他们需要来自某个地方的录制音乐，这将给他们的粉丝提供他们想要的、那种新鲜、令人兴奋、低音沉重的舞曲。考克斯森·多德成为第一批做出决定的音响人之一，这个决定表面上很简单，但将改变牙买加音乐。
But he didn't really play any instruments himself. He was a trained auto mechanic and carpenter, a left-brain technician with experience building speaker cabinets for other sound system crews. And he realized he had all the skills he needed to start his own sound system. Which he did. He called it Sir Coxons Downbeat. And Sir Coxon quickly became one of the premier soundmen of his era, known for dropping bebop and blues cuts alongside the more predictable R&B dance dance. By the mid-50s, Kingston Sound System Dance scene was getting very crowded.
更大胆的时候，我们意识到我们必须真正制作一些我们自己的音乐来让人们快乐。所以去了录音室开始录音。虽然很多艺术家已经从金斯顿移民，但周围仍然有一些伟大的音乐人。多德把其中一些艺术家召集到他能在城里租到的任何录音室里。我们做了一些节奏蓝调，试图用那种强劲的节奏复制节奏蓝调。经过几次会议后，你看到所有人都接受了它。你觉得你知道你做了一首好曲子。
The guys who ran them came from all different walks of life. Dodd had been a migrant farmer and an auto mechanic. Duke Reed was a former cop known for openly carrying loaded guns at his dance parties. Duke Reed, Cox and Dodd and other soundmen often found themselves spinning right down the block from one another, vying for the attention of party goers looking for the best place to dance. So initially it would be two or more dance hall performances competing in the same neighborhood and it was who could draw a bigger crowd. And the expression is that all the crowd went to your dance rather than to another you
这些会议是用一种叫醋酸盐的塑料材料录制的。录音并不打算持久。多德只需要足够在他的音响系统上播放十几次的东西。多德并不是唯一这样做的人。其他音响人开始召集艺术家并租用金斯顿周围几个录音室的时间。音响系统所有者雇佣一些音乐人来录制他们自己版本的美国音乐，你知道。所以有一堆早期的牙买加录音，他们称之为“JA布吉”。本质上是R&B，跳跃驱动，你知道，在牙买加录制，带有一些牙买加的转折，但不多。本质上，它是对在美国录制的内容的相当忠实的复制。但对于牙买加作为一个国家来说，事情正在迅速改变。20世纪50年代中期，这个英国殖民地在独立运动上踩下了油门。一种真正的民族自豪感正在显现，一种你在任何地方都能感受到的对牙买加身份的信仰。人们想表达自己是牙买加人，人们比从美国进口文化更坚定地创造自己的文化。
fucked the dance of the other sound man. It wasn't long before some promoters decided to make things a little more interesting. By having sound systems go head to head, kind of like a battle of the bands. And these became what are now called sound system clashes, where two sound systems were more, would play against each other in a competitive musical battle.
音乐人和音响人决定是时候制作一些感觉不那么衍生品的东西了。他们心想，好吧，这还不错，但我们已经播放这些东西很久了。我们应该制作一些更属于我们自己的东西。你知道，我们应该在上面加上我们自己的转折。某个50年代末的一个周日早上，考克斯森·多德邀请当时的一些顶级艺术家聚集在金斯顿他家酒铺的后屋里。考克斯森和一群音乐人开会说，看，我们必须做点什么，你知道？他们都感到非常兴奋，哦，上周，我们可以表达自己一点。他们想在音乐中加入一位艺术家所说的“牙买加感觉”。对于多德强大的工程师、音乐人和制作人团队来说，这意味着调整节奏结构。多德非常喜欢美国R&B中那种经典的洗牌节奏。但音乐人决定将重点从第一和第三拍改为第二和第四拍，即所谓的“后拍”。
At a clash, each sound system would typically get a set amount of time to spend. They'd go back and forth trying to win the crowd's unequivocal love. Early in his career, Coxon.1 clashes against veteran soundmen like Duke Reed. These victories were crucial because they helped establish Coxon as one of the best sound system operators in the game. Winning sound clashes and throwing unforgettable dances was bigger than just bragging rights. In just a few short years, the sound system scene had become incredibly lucrative, supporting not just sound crews, but security details, drivers, venue owners, and more. It was bragging rights for the sound system and their supporters, but also economic survival
所以从这样的东西，变成这样的东西。起初他们称之为“颠倒的R&B”。现在这看起来可能只是表面上的一个小调整，但随着这种向弱拍的转变，多德的团队即将构思出牙买加全新的现代声音。在那次后屋会议后的第二天，它与钢琴家和歌手一起演唱，
was wrapped up in who was going to eventually win a clash. Fruit and fish hawkers, jerk chicken vendors, all sorts of people who were dependent on this homegrown scene would flock to the gates of the dance. The sound system plays a very important part in the a lot of industry. This is King Jammy again. It plays a vital part in people selling things at the dance. It plays an important part for the weed man selling weed and a lot of things, you know. So it became a kind of informal economy for people who were chronically under employed and looking for ways to earn extra money.
那位叫贝克福德的歌手，叫《轻松折断》。它被广泛认为是后来被称为“斯卡”的流派中的第一首录制歌曲，这种风格呼应了美国R&B，但它显然是它自己的东西。人们谈论《轻松折断》是第一首斯卡歌曲，因为它颠倒了节奏的重点。但也许为什么工作在里面。那种新的斯卡节奏让音响系统派对上的舞者完全疯狂了。他们喜欢它。像《轻松折断》这样的歌曲帮助斯卡在整个牙买加变得极其流行。但如果你喜欢这种新音乐，舞会仍然几乎是唯一能听到它的地方。当多德制作那些第一批录音时，他只专注于为他的音响系统提供音乐，而不是把它卖给公众。当我们开始时，我们没有想到这可以是一门生意，这些唱片在那个时候仍然是那样。所以在那一点上，人们只是制作唱片在他们的音响系统上播放，唱片的独特性是它重要的原因，它的价值在于它的独特性。如果周围有半打副本，那么它就不像只有一份时那么有价值。所以你可以卖唱片的想法对大多数音响人来说是荒谬的。这违背了他们所看到的一切。好吧，为什么不呢？这就是我想要更多副本的原因，你知道？但多德很快改变了关于保持一切独家的想法。
When it came to staying ahead of the competition, sound system crews could be relentless. At a clash, one crew might even stoop to sabotage, cutting speaker wires or starting fights, just to derail the competition. And there were other ways that DJ Crews fought to stay on top. See, lots of King Stoneians relied on sound system parties to hear new music. Most people didn't have record players, and Jamaican radio wasn't playing the edgy or party tracks they wanted to hear. So if that's the kind of stuff you liked, you had to go to the dance. And that's exactly what King Stonians did. They headed to San system parties and looked
他一直听到关于他为他的“节拍”音响系统制作的音乐的嗡嗡声。人们到处说，如果他确实录制了那些东西并卖给公众，那绝对是一个市场。这非常强烈，人们说，不要害怕，不要制作那个唱片。我说，说出来真是不可思议，我说，是的，伙计，所以我们会给你那个尝试。
to the DJs to spin the freshest cuts. And this is why the most precious thing that a sound man could have was a song that was new and that nobody else had. They were known as exclusives. A lot of that music was imported or brought to Jamaica by people like Cox and Dodd. And for most DJs, those records were priceless. The musical side was really about having exclusives. Frank Broughton is the co-author of the book, Last Nighted DJ Save My Life, a history of DJ.
所以在1959年，多德压制了《轻松折断》的副本并开始销售它们。多德把它带到了周围。我很惊讶它真的卖出去了。他是第一批人之一。那是一个开始，不是一门生意，因为那时我们意识到，你知道，它可以是一门生意，因为像那样的唱片卖得很多。这就是行业开始的方式，你知道，几个骑摩托车的家伙四处走动，把这些东西卖给唱片盒所有者。这种音乐，音响人帮助它变得鲜活，标志着岛上录音业的开始，诞生于舞厅的需求。音响系统在50年代点燃的音乐革命在接下来的几十年里变得更加激烈。1962年，考克斯森·多德引进了牙买加一些最好的音响系统工程师，他们帮助他为岛上的音乐场景建立了一个生产中心。多德将其命名为“牙买加录音和出版录音室”。但从来没有人那样称呼它。对于许多将在那里录音的著名艺术家，包括李·佩里、斯卡托莱特乐队和怀勒乐队，它简称为“一号录音室”。许多其他音响人效仿多德的榜样，在首都各地开设录音室。这是60年代初，牙买加刚刚赢得了独立。
The sound system guys would go to America to get rhythm and blues records, and it would be all about which exclusive tracks you could get that would really make the crowd go crazy that your opposition didn't have. And they had signature tunes that might be something that might be the only copy on the island. The competition became relentless between the sound systems. They were sending people up to the United States
一股强烈的黑人文化自豪感，甚至黑人民族主义，主要由拉斯塔法里信仰的爆发所领导，正在席卷全岛。它成为当地艺术家正在录制并现在销售的内容的决定性部分。牙买加人正在听到他们自己和他们的抱负在他们的音乐中反映出来，公众对此欲罢不能。它越来越关乎文化自豪感，最终我认为是关于对他们自己文化形式的政治自主权的主张，他们想要在家里创造的东西，并且反映了牙买加的现实。然后，在20世纪60年代末，牙买加以图图·内姆·托斯的《做雷鬼》等歌曲震撼了世界，展示了岛上最决定性的声音。
to go on scouting expeditions to find records. And then there was also a lot of detected work to try to sluth out what your competitors records were or that they were keeping secret. To be exclusive, you should scratch off the label. Monty Blake, whose father started the Maritime Sound System, remembers the extreme measures sound men took just to keep the records super secret. Because those days you had spies.
去进行探寻唱片的考察。此外，还有大量侦查工作，试图探明竞争对手的唱片，或者他们保密的唱片。为了保持独家性，你应该刮掉唱片标签。蒙蒂·布莱克（Monty Blake）的父亲创办了海事音响系统（Maritime Sound System），他记得音响师为了对唱片严格保密而采取的极端措施。因为在那个年代，有间谍存在。
They knew the color once they see a yellow and black they know it's speciality and they see a red and black they know it's speciality, and they see a red and black they know it's Atlantic. King Jamming says this practice was pretty common for guys who ran sound systems. The scratch out the name, nobody don't really know who's singing our what's the name of the song. So the players are exclusive songs, and they'll play it for months until you know, until the other guy finds out who is the singer or what's the name of the song. And after erasing the name of the artist and the record label, soundmen would sometimes even rename the now anonymous tune. Then they dropped the new cut at a party, and folks would go nuts. At least, that was the dream. This whole process was one of the earliest iterations
他们一旦看到黄色和黑色，就知道是Speciality唱片公司的；看到红色和黑色，就知道是Atlantic唱片公司的。金·杰明（King Jamming）说，这种做法在经营音响系统的人中很常见。刮掉名字，没人真正知道是谁唱的，或者歌名是什么。所以播放者拥有独家歌曲，他们会播放几个月，直到其他人发现歌手是谁或歌名是什么。在抹去艺术家名字和唱片标签后，音响师有时甚至会给这首匿名的曲子重新命名。然后他们在派对上播放新曲子，人们会为之疯狂。至少，这是梦想。整个过程是后来在DJ文化中变得非常熟悉的事物的最早迭代之一。
of a thing that would become really familiar in DJ culture. The one who got all the love for the music wasn't the person who actually created it. It was the DJ. The props were for his skills in reading the crowd, his taste in music, and his access to the best dance cuts. But by the second half of the 1950s, the US to Jamaica pipeline that for years kept the
对音乐给予所有赞美的人并不是真正创作它的人，而是DJ。赞誉归功于他解读人群的技巧、他的音乐品味以及他获得最佳舞曲的能力。但到了20世纪50年代下半叶，多年来一直保持着
sound system DJ's crates filled with jazz, blues, and R&B records was starting to go dry. And this was about to be a problem for the dancing. Blame it on rock and roll. In America, the rhythm on blue was kinda fed and dined out. Then came the rock and roll. But the rock and roll didn't go over strongly in Jamaica. Rock and roll exploded in the mid-1950s. But with its pushy winding guitars and no discernible dance beat,
音响系统DJ唱片箱里装满爵士、蓝调和R&B唱片的美国通往牙买加的渠道开始枯竭。这即将成为舞蹈的一个问题。这得怪摇滚乐。在美国，节奏蓝调有点被冷落了。然后摇滚乐出现了。但摇滚乐在牙买加并没有引起强烈反响。摇滚乐在20世纪50年代中期爆发。但由于其咄咄逼人的吉他声和没有明显的舞蹈节拍，
West Kingston's party crowd was not feeling it. And as Rock & Roll became king in the US, soundmen like Dodd founded Harder & Harder to get their hands on the kind of bottom heavy jazz and R&B that Jamaicans loved, and that sounded amazing on those giant speakers. Actually, America's running out of this stuff. Tastes were shifting by that point. There wasn't so much kind of Louis Jordan and all of that.
西金斯顿的派对人群并不买账。随着摇滚乐在美国称王，像多德（Dodd）这样的音响师开始更加努力地寻找牙买加人喜爱的、在那些巨型扬声器上听起来很棒的低音沉重的爵士和R&B音乐。事实上，美国这类音乐快用完了。当时人们的口味正在转变。路易斯·乔丹（Louis Jordan）那一类的音乐已经不多了。
At the same time, there were just more sounds to some around, and everybody was drawing from this dwindling pool of fresh American R&B. Dodd and others could see the writing on the wall. They poured a lot into their sound system businesses, and it was paying well, but only if you could maintain your competitive edge, which was getting harder and harder to do. They needed recorded music from somewhere that would give their fans the kind of fresh, exciting, bassy dance music that they wanted. In Cox and Dodd became one of the first soundmen to make a decision that was pretty simple on its surface, but would transform Jamaican music.
与此同时，周围的音响系统更多了，每个人都在从这个日益枯竭的新鲜美国R&B资源池中汲取资源。多德和其他人预见到了这一点。他们在音响系统业务上投入了大量资金，回报也很丰厚，但前提是你必须保持竞争优势，而这变得越来越难。他们需要从某个地方获得录制好的音乐，为粉丝提供他们想要的、新鲜、令人兴奋、充满低音的舞曲。考克森·多德（Coxsone Dodd）成为了第一批做出一个表面上很简单，但却会改变牙买加音乐的决定的音响师之一。
A bolder time, we realized we had to really make some music of our own to keep the people happy. So went in the studio and started recording. Although a lot of artists had migrated out of Kingston, there were still some great musicians around. And Dodd corralled a few of those artists into whatever studios he could rant around the city. We did some rhythm and blues, tried to copy the rhythm and blues with that driving beat. And after a couple of sessions, you see all the people accept it. You feel that you know you're done a good track.
在一个更大胆的时代，我们意识到我们必须真正制作一些自己的音乐来让人们快乐。所以我们进了录音室开始录音。虽然许多艺术家已经离开了金斯顿，但周围仍然有一些伟大的音乐家。多德把其中一些艺术家召集到他在城里能租到的任何录音室里。我们做了一些节奏蓝调，试图用那种强劲的节拍复制节奏蓝调。经过几次录音后，你看到所有人都接受了它。你感觉到你知道你做了一首好曲子。
These sessions were recorded on a plastic material called acetate. The recordings were not meant to last. Dodges needed something good enough for a dozen or so spins on his sound system. Dodd wasn't the only producer doing this. Other soundmen started pulling together artists and renting time in one of several studios around Kingston. Sound system owners with higher, some musicians to record their own versions of American music, you know. So there's a bunch of early Jamaican recordings,
这些录音是记录在一种叫醋酸盐的塑料材料上的。这些录音并不打算长久保存。多德只需要足够在他的音响系统上播放十几次的东西。多德并不是唯一这样做的人。其他音响师开始召集艺术家，并租用金斯顿周围的几家录音室的时间。音响系统所有者会雇佣一些音乐家来录制他们自己版本的美国音乐。所以，有一堆早期的牙买加录音，
which they call it J.A. Boogie. Essentially it's R&B, Jump Drive, you know, being recorded in Jamaica with a few Jamaican twists, but not much. Essentially, it was a fairly faithful reproduction of what had been recorded in the US. But things were changing fast for Jamaica as a nation. In the mid-1950s, the British colony hit the gas on a campaign for independence. A real air of national pride was emerging, a faith in Jamaicanness that you could feel everywhere. People wanted to express themselves as Jamaicans, and people were far more determined to create their own culture than to import it from America.
他们称之为“牙买加布吉”（J.A. Boogie）。本质上是R&B，跳跃节奏，在牙买加录制，带有一些牙买加特色，但不多。本质上，这是对美国录制内容的相当忠实的复制。但牙买加作为一个国家，情况正在迅速变化。20世纪50年代中期，这个英国殖民地加快了独立运动的步伐。一种真正的民族自豪感正在兴起，一种随处可见的对“牙买加性”的信仰。人们想表达自己作为牙买加人的身份，人们比以往任何时候都更决心创造自己的文化，而不是从美国进口。
The musicians and soundmen decided it was time to make something that felt less derivative. They were thinking, well, it's kind of all right, but we've been playing this stuff for ages. We ought to be making something that a bit more of our own. You know, we ought to be putting our own twists on it. One Sunday morning, sometime in the late 50s, Cawkson Dodd invited some of the top artists at the time to huddle in the back room of his family's liquor store in Kingston. Cawkson had a meeting with a bunch of musicians and said, look, we've got to do something,
音乐家和音响师决定是时候制作一些不那么衍生性的东西了。他们心想，好吧，这还不错，但我们已经演奏这些东西很久了。我们应该制作一些更属于我们自己的东西。你知道，我们应该加入我们自己的特色。50年代末的一个周日上午，考克森·多德邀请了当时的一些顶级艺术家聚集在他位于金斯顿的家族酒铺的后屋。考克森和一群音乐家开了个会，说，听着，我们必须做点什么，
you know? And they all felt quite excited about, oh, last week, we can express ourselves a bit. They wanted to add to the music what one of the artists called a Jamaican feeling. For Dodd's powerhouse team of engineers, musicians, and producers, that meant fudzing with the rhythm structure. Dodd really liked that classic shuffle beat found in American R&B. But the musicians decided to change the emphasis from the first and third beats to the second and fourth beats, what's known as the afterbeat.
你知道吗？他们都感到非常兴奋，哦，最后我们能表达一下自己了。他们想在音乐中加入一位艺术家所说的“牙买加感觉”。对于多德强大的工程师、音乐家和制作人团队来说，这意味着要调整节奏结构。多德非常喜欢美国R&B中那种经典的曳步节拍。但音乐家们决定将重点从第一和第三拍转移到第二和第四拍，也就是所谓的“后拍”（afterbeat）。
So from something like this, to something like this. At first they called it upside down R&B. Now it might seem like a small tweak on the surface, but with this shift to the offbeat, Dodd's team was about to conceive a whole new modern sound in Jamaica. The day after that backroom meeting, it is sung with pianist and singer,
所以从这样的节奏，变成这样的节奏。起初他们称之为“颠倒的R&B”。现在这看起来可能只是表面上的一个小调整，但随着这种向弱拍的转变，多德的团队即将构思出牙买加一种全新的现代声音。在那个后屋会议的第二天，它由钢琴家兼歌手演唱，
the offalist Beckford, called Easy Snapping. It's widely regarded as the first recorded song in a genre that would later be called SCA, a style that echoes American R&B, but it is clearly its own thing. People talking about easy snack business first-scar song because it inverted the emphasis in the beats. But maybe why a job's inside. That new sky rhythm made the dancers at Sound System parties go totally nuts. They loved it. And songs like Easy Snapping helped make sky immensely popular all over Jamaica. But if you were into this new music, the dance parties were still pretty much the only places
名为《Easy Snapping》。它被广泛认为是后来被称为斯卡（Ska）流派的第一首录制歌曲，这种风格呼应了美国R&B，但它显然有自己的特色。人们谈论《Easy Snapping》是第一首斯卡歌曲，因为它颠倒了节拍的重点。那种新的斯卡节奏让音响系统派对上的舞者完全疯狂了。他们喜欢它。像《Easy Snapping》这样的歌曲帮助斯卡在整个牙买加变得极其流行。但如果你喜欢这种新音乐，舞会仍然几乎是唯一的地方
to hear it. And when Dodd made those first recordings, he was focused only on supplying music to his sound system, not selling it to the general public. When we started, we didn't have a idea this could be a business, these records were still at that point. So that point, people were only making records to play on their sound systems and the uniqueness of a record was what made it important, what its value lay in its uniqueness. If there was even half a dozen copies of it knocking about against them, then it wasn't
能听到它。当多德制作那些第一批录音时，他只专注于为他的音响系统提供音乐，而不是卖给公众。当我们开始时，我们没想到这能成为一门生意，这些唱片在当时仍然是那样。所以在那一点上，人们制作唱片只是为了在他们的音响系统上播放，唱片的独特性是它重要的原因，它的价值在于它的独特性。如果外面有哪怕六张拷贝，那么它就
nearly as valuable as if there was only one. So the idea that you could sell records was ridiculous to most soundmen. It just went against everything they saw. Well, why not? That's what I want more copies of this out there, you know? But Dodd soon changed his mind about keeping everything exclusive.
不像只有一张时那么有价值。所以卖唱片的想法对大多数音响师来说是荒谬的。这违背了他们所看到的一切。嗯，为什么不呢？这就是我想要更多拷贝流传出去的原因，你知道吗？但多德很快改变了关于保持一切独家的想法。
He'd been hearing buzz about the music that he was making for his downbeat sound system. Folks here and there saying, if he did record that stuff and sell it to the public, that was definitely a market. This was so strong people said, don't be afraid, don't make a record of that. I said, it's incredible to say, I said, yeah, man, so we'll give you that try.
他一直听到关于他为他的Downbeat音响系统制作的音乐的传闻。到处都有人说，如果他录制那些东西并卖给公众，那绝对是一个市场。这种呼声非常强烈，人们说，别害怕，录制一张唱片吧。我说，这太不可思议了，我说，好吧，伙计，那我们就试试看。
So in 1959, Dodd pressed up copies of Easy Snapping and started selling them. Dodd took it round. I was astonished that he actually sold. He was one of the first. That was a start, not a business because then we realized, you know, it could be a business because records like that sort of a lot. And that's how the industry started with, you know, a couple of guys on motorbikes going around selling these things to group box owners. This music, which the soundmen had helped bring to life, marked the beginning of the island's recording industry, born out of the needs of the dance hall. The musical revolution that the sound system had ignited in the 1950s got more intense
所以在1959年，多德压制了《Easy Snapping》的拷贝并开始销售。多德把它带到各处。我很惊讶它真的卖出去了。他是第一批这样做的人之一。那是一个开始，而不是一门生意，因为后来我们意识到，你知道，这可以是一门生意，因为像那样的唱片卖得很多。这就是行业开始的方式，你知道，几个骑摩托车的家伙到处把这些东西卖给唱片店老板。这种音响师帮助实现的音乐，标志着该岛录音工业的开始，诞生于舞厅的需求。音响系统在20世纪50年代点燃的音乐革命变得更加激烈，
over the next couple of decades. In 1962, Coxandod brought in some of Jamaica's best sound system engineers, and they helped him build a production hub for the island's music scene. Dodd named it the Jamaica Recording and Publishing Studio. But no one ever called it that. To the many famous artists who would record there, including Lee Perry, the Scatolites, and the Whalers, it was simply Studio One. Lots of other soundmen followed Dott's example, opening studios across the capital city. This was the early 60s, and Jamaica had just earned its independence.
在接下来的几十年里。1962年，考克森·多德引进了牙买加一些最好的音响系统工程师，他们帮助他建立了一个岛上音乐场景的制作中心。多德将其命名为“牙买加录音与出版工作室”（Jamaica Recording and Publishing Studio）。但从来没有人那样称呼它。对于许多在那里录音的著名艺术家，包括李·佩里（Lee Perry）、斯卡特莱特乐队（The Skatalites）和怀勒乐队（The Wailers）来说，它简称为“Studio One”。许多其他音响师效仿多德的榜样，在首都各地开设录音室。那是60年代初，牙买加刚刚赢得了独立。
A strong current of black cultural pride and even black nationalism led mainly by the explosion of the Rastafari faith was sweeping the island. It became a definitive part of what local artists were recording and now selling. Jamaicans were hearing themselves and their ambitions reflected back to them in their music, and the public could not get enough. It became increasingly about cultural pride, and then ultimately I think about an assertion of a political autonomy over their own cultural forms, and they wanted things that were created at home, and that reflected the Jamaican reality. And then, in the late 1960s, Jamaica hit the world with songs like Do the Reggae by Tutsu Name Tows showcasing the island's most definitive sound ever.
一股强大的黑人文化自豪感，甚至黑人民族主义潮流，主要由拉斯塔法里教（Rastafari）的兴起所引领，正在席卷全岛。它成为了当地艺术家正在录制并现在销售的内容的一个决定性部分。牙买加人听到他们自己和他们的抱负在音乐中得到了反映，公众对此需求旺盛。这越来越关乎文化自豪感，最终我认为是关于对自身文化形式的政治自主权的主张，他们想要在本土创造的、反映牙买加现实的东西。然后，在20世纪60年代末，牙买加以图茨和梅塔尔乐队（Toots and the Maytals）的《Do the Reggae》等歌曲震撼了世界，展示了该岛有史以来最明确的声音。
Reggae grew out of Skah and a subsequent style called Rock Steadie. But Reggae quickly surpassed both as the country's single most popular musical form. It was album-oriented, it was radio-friendly, labels in the US and the UK picked it up and packaged it for international markets. And by the time I went to college in Ohio in the early 90s, just about every student in my dorm had a copy of Bob Marley's legend and a poster of him on the wall
雷鬼音乐源于斯卡音乐（Skah）和随后出现的摇滚稳步音乐（Rock Steady）。但雷鬼音乐很快就超越了这两种风格，成为该国最受欢迎的音乐形式。它以专辑为导向，适合电台播放，美国和英国的唱片公司纷纷将其收录并推向国际市场。到90年代初我在俄亥俄州上大学时，我宿舍里的每个学生几乎都有一张鲍勃·马利的《Legend》专辑，墙上还贴着他的海报。
as if they were handed out at orientation. The culture that emerged when those first humble sound systems popped up in West Kingston, playing American jazz and blues. That same culture had spawned Jamaica's first recording industry, and it led to modern music styles with global reach. Many people think that the Jamaican recording industry grew up and that the sound systems were there to popularize the records. Well, it was actually quite the opposite.
就好像这些东西是在迎新会上发的一样。当西金斯顿首次出现那些简陋的音响系统并播放美国爵士乐和蓝调音乐时，这种文化便随之诞生了。正是这种文化催生了牙买加最早的唱片业，并引领了具有全球影响力的现代音乐风格。许多人认为牙买加唱片业是先发展起来的，而音响系统只是为了推广唱片。嗯，事实恰恰相反。
The sound system then actually went into the studio to record records so that they could have exclusives for their sound system. So the recording industry was actually a byproduct of the sound systems and not the other way around. Sound systems made Jamaican music and international sound. Coming up after the break, how a sound system culture has influenced a lot of other music that we love. From hip hop to reggae tone to EDM. Since the 1980s, sound system culture has reached way beyond reggae. The innovations of soundmen are deep and a lot of the stuff that we listen to now. One of the best examples, dub. Producers invented dub by taking reggae recordings
音响系统经营者实际上是进入录音室录制唱片，这样他们就能拥有自己音响系统的独家曲目。所以唱片业实际上是音响系统的副产品，而不是反过来。音响系统造就了牙买加音乐和国际化的声音。休息过后，我们将探讨音响系统文化如何影响了我们喜爱的许多其他音乐。从嘻哈到雷鬼舞曲再到电子舞曲（EDM）。自20世纪80年代以来，音响系统文化的影响力早已超越了雷鬼音乐。音响技术人员的创新非常深远，影响了我们现在听到的许多音乐。最好的例子之一就是Dub音乐。制作人通过获取雷鬼录音来发明Dub音乐
and chopping them up, shuffling instruments, adding sound effects, and then reconstructing everything into entirely new songs. Dub music turned studio engineers into arrangers. They relied heavily on advances in audio technology, especially multi-track recording. And at first, Dub was created exclusively for sound systems. Frank Broughton says that Dub and the sound system culture
并将它们切碎、重新排列乐器、添加音效，然后将一切重构成全新的歌曲。Dub音乐将录音室工程师变成了编曲人。他们非常依赖音频技术的进步，尤其是多轨录音。起初，Dub音乐是专门为音响系统创作的。弗兰克·布劳顿（Frank Broughton）说，Dub音乐和音响系统文化
that created it had a huge impact on the way that music is made and performed today. It laid down the principles of remixing. It made an artist and a star of the producer. Here's Frank reading a little bit from the book he co-authored last night at DJ Save My Life. It transformed playing records
创造了它，并对当今音乐的制作和表演方式产生了巨大影响。它奠定了混音的原则。它让制作人成为了艺术家和明星。这是弗兰克昨晚在《DJ拯救我的生命》（DJ Save My Life）一书中朗读的一小段内容。它改变了播放唱片的方式
into a live performance and it showed how music could be propelled into whole new genres by the needs of the dance floor. And even though these kinds of ideas developed independently in other music scenes, Broughton says Jamaica did them first. The soundment were among the first DJs to be seen as celebrities. Behind the sound system turntable, the DJ, maybe more than the artist that they're spinning becomes the hero.
使其成为一种现场表演，并展示了音乐如何因舞池的需求而被推向全新的流派。尽管这些想法在其他音乐场景中是独立发展的，但布劳顿说牙买加人是先行者。音响技术人员是最早被视为名人的DJ之一。在音响系统的转盘后面，DJ可能比他们播放的艺术家更成为英雄。
And over the last 50 years, the influence of sound system culture has gone way beyond Jamaica. In New York City, artists with roots in the Caribbean were heavily influenced by Jamaican music trends. Especially this hugely popular part of the sound system scene where Jamaican MCs like Big Youth, Prince Jazzbo, and Iroy toasted in Patoa over instrumental reggae records. And the Bronx artists like Funky Four Plus one more picked up mics and rap while DJs spun disco and funk breaks. And then there's England. Sound systems in the UK were really the initial gene pool that created all the dance music that is indigenous to the UK. By 1968, nearly 200,000 Jamaicans had made the post-war to migration to England.
在过去的50年里，音响系统文化的影响力早已超越了牙买加。在纽约市，有着加勒比血统的艺术家深受牙买加音乐潮流的影响。特别是音响系统场景中非常受欢迎的一部分，即像Big Youth、Prince Jazzbo和Iroy这样的牙买加MC在器乐雷鬼唱片上用帕托阿语（Patoa）进行即兴说唱（Toasting）。而布朗克斯的艺术家，如Funky Four Plus One More，拿起麦克风进行说唱，同时DJ播放迪斯科和放克音乐的间奏。还有英国。英国的音响系统实际上是创造所有英国本土舞曲的原始基因库。到1968年，近20万牙买加人完成了战后向英国的移民。
Many brought with them the culture of sound systems, which took deep root in places like Bristol and Birmingham, spawning some legendary DJ crews. British and Jamaican producers continued to make reggae and other music designed especially for those sound systems. Engineers kept building more and more powerful rigs to blow everyone's minds. There's a direct line from UK sound systems to other British music that emerged from the 80s on. The sound system was more than just reggae. It could be this thing that transmitted other music. And without that, you wouldn't have, you know, the indigenous British dance music,
许多人带来了音响系统文化，这种文化在布里斯托尔和伯明翰等地深深扎根，催生了一些传奇的DJ团队。英国和牙买加的制作人继续制作专门为这些音响系统设计的雷鬼音乐和其他音乐。工程师们不断建造越来越强大的设备来震撼人心。从英国音响系统到80年代以后出现的其他英国音乐，有一条直接的脉络。音响系统不仅仅是雷鬼音乐。它可以是传播其他音乐的载体。没有它，你就不会有，你知道的，本土的英国舞曲，
like jungle and drum and bass and garage, it was all from the sound systems. Frank also says that the way sound system engineers, DJs and dub producers have always been willing to play. The way they experiment so freely with sound and technology, all of that has really influenced British dance music. Even little techniques that West Kingston DJs first dreamed up decades ago, some of those are now cliches in electronic dance music.
比如丛林音乐（Jungle）、鼓打贝斯（Drum and Bass）和车库音乐（Garage），它们都源自音响系统。弗兰克还说，音响系统工程师、DJ和Dub制作人一直乐于尝试。他们如此自由地试验声音和技术的方式，所有这些都真正影响了英国舞曲。即使是几十年前西金斯顿DJ最初构思的一些小技巧，现在也成了电子舞曲中的陈词滥调。
I mean, one of the cheesiest tricks of an EDM record is that you drop the bass line out, and there's that expectation that you really want that to come back. So after this long break, it suddenly comes wondering back. And that's fundamental. You know, those sort of things are fundamental to most dance records, and first done in sound systems. You know, that all came from Jamaica. When Herbie Miller, our party chaser from the intro, was growing up in Kingston, he enjoyed seeing the couples at Sound System Dancers move together to the music.
我的意思是，EDM唱片中最俗气的技巧之一就是把低音线去掉，人们会有一种期待，非常希望它能回来。所以在漫长的停顿之后，它突然又回来了。这是基础。你知道，这些东西是大多数舞曲的基础，而且最早是在音响系统中完成的。你知道，这一切都来自牙买加。当我们的开场嘉宾赫比·米勒（Herbie Miller）在金斯顿长大时，他喜欢看音响系统舞池里的情侣们随着音乐一起舞动。
He might see a girl he liked, invite her out into the dance floor, and feel how those awesome speakers made the whole place just shake. Herbys had a long career in music. He was once Peter Tash's manager, and today he directs and curates the Jamaica Music Museum, and he gets a big ol' smile when he talks about seeing his country's music go global. Can you imagine when some systems came into being in Jamaica, nobody imagined that the world would be a son system world regardless of where in the world you enter.
他可能会看到一个喜欢的女孩，邀请她到舞池，感受那些震撼的扬声器如何让整个地方震动。赫比在音乐界有着长期的职业生涯。他曾是彼得·托什（Peter Tosh）的经纪人，今天他指导并策划了牙买加音乐博物馆，当他谈到看到自己国家的音乐走向全球时，脸上露出了灿烂的笑容。你能想象吗？当音响系统在牙买加诞生时，没有人想到世界会变成一个音响系统的世界，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。
But it still kinda blows his mind that so much of it came from this little party scene in the middle of the Caribbean. And not you know, just the dumb thing about this little brother scene in the middle of the Caribbean. And not you know, that's the dumb thing about this little violin in Oman. Oh, the hell did they come up with this big old box? Are you running some music to it? And take over the world with it. I can't answer that question.
但他仍然觉得不可思议，这一切竟然源于加勒比海中部这个小小的派对场景。这太不可思议了。他们到底是怎么想出这个大盒子的？你往里面放音乐，然后用它征服世界。我无法回答这个问题。
But as some of my brethren would say, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I just, I the works of the works. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Christopher Johnson, edited by Emmett Fitzgerald, sound mix in additional production by Martin Gonzalez, music by director of sound Swan Rihale, additional music by our former superstar intern Keiko Donald with production help from her sister Kayla Donald, it's so nice to have you back, Keiko. Delaney Hall is our senior editor Kurt Colestad is the digital director. The resident includes Vivian Le, Lashmidon, Chris Barouba, Jason Dalyone, Jacob Maldonado Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars.
但正如我的一些兄弟会说的那样，我只是……（重复词汇省略）……这是《99%无形》（99% Invisible）本周由克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）制作，埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）编辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martin Gonzalez）负责混音和额外制作，音乐由声音总监斯旺·里哈勒（Swan Rihale）负责，额外音乐由我们前超级实习生凯科·唐纳德（Keiko Donald）提供，并得到了她妹妹凯拉·唐纳德（Kayla Donald）的制作帮助，凯科，很高兴你回来。德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是我们的高级编辑，库尔特·科尔斯塔德（Kurt Colestad）是数字总监。团队成员包括薇薇安·勒（Vivian Le）、拉什米·多恩（Lashmidon）、克里斯·巴鲁巴（Chris Barouba）、杰森·戴利恩（Jason Dalyone）、雅各布·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳（Jacob Maldonado Medina）、凯利·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）以及我，罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。
Special thanks to Carter Van Pelt from Coney Island Reggae and VP Music Group for editorial assistance. We are a part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 9-9-PI org. We're on Instagram, Reddit, and now TikTok too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI, and 99PI. I love it.
特别感谢来自Coney Island Reggae和VP Music Group的卡特·范·佩尔特（Carter Van Pelt）提供的编辑协助。我们是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大厦。位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心，非常漂亮。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIorg。我们在Instagram、Reddit上，现在也有TikTok。你可以找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接，以及《99PI》的每一期往期节目，我爱《99PI》。
Darl, Darl, Darl, Darl, Darl, Darl, Darl, Darl, Darl, Darl, Darl, Darl, Darl, Darl, Darl, Darl, Darl, Darl, Darl, you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
（重复词汇省略）……这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。